bonjour a cassé alors quel est l'objet
de ce rassemblement et bien qu'on lui
tend enfin véritablement contre les
violences faites aux femmes
il y à là aujourd'hui les principales
associations féministes rejoindre par
des ong des syndicats des partis
politiques quel tel que le parti
communiste français élevés la france
insoumise le npa tous les participants
ici de nombreux citoyens
évidemment souhaite qu'on en finisse
avec les viols les agressions sexuelles
toute forme de violence faite aux femmes
juste un chiffre qui fait froid dans le
dos plus de 142 mille plaintes pour
violences conjugales déposée en 2019 ses
16 % de plus qu'en 2018 et le
confinement encore aggravé les choses
voilà que peut faire le grenelle et bien
malheureusement pas assez il est très
insuffisant estiment les participants
qui demande un milliard pour davantage
de protection des femmes des places
d'hébergement et puis des campagnes
digne de ce nom pour lutter contre les
violences
on écoute danielle simonnet clémentine
autain élus et député la france
insoumise qui étaient présentes à ce
rassemblement
on vient d'un ou d'apprendre que le
gouvernement avait l'intention de
d'ouvrir un marché pour remettre en
concurrence le 39 19 qui est le numéro
d'appel d'urgence contre les violences
sexistes et sexuelles faites aux femmes
mais nous ne voulons pas que ce soit une
entreprise privée qui s'en occupe c'est
tout mouvement associatif ministre qui
en a les compétences de s'en occuper
c'est par un marché ce gouvernement de
l'extrême marché et prennent y compris à
faire des violences faites aux femmes
un business vous savez qu'il ya une loi
contre les violences faites aux femmes
qui étaient en scène la grande loi du
quinquennat on a débattu malheureusement
dans des conditions délit puisque l ena
docteur première route
donc cette loi est évident de moyens
alors que nous revendiquons et une fois
longtemps une loi pas vraiment c'est à
dire une loi qui ressemble rêve a été
fait en allemagne et qui permettent de
déployer les moyens nous la justice pour
la prévention pour l'accompagnement des
victimes pour l'hébergement d'urgence et
terra parce qu'aujourd'hui le monde ce
qui fait des mots ce sont les moyens
parmi elle est prise de parole celle de
corinne leriche la mère de la jeune
julie qui accuse une vingtaine de
pompiers de l'avoir violée alors qu'elle
n'avait que 13 ans et oui encore un
autre scandale
et pourtant la cour d'appel de
versailles avait rejeté la
requalification on viole au profit de
celle d'atteintes sexuelles
il ya donc actuellement d'autres prises
de paroles pour un rassemblement qui va
se terminer à 14 heures merci à catia
pour toute cette précision